olha eu num
eu não tenho nada a dizer sinceramente
não tem porque a essas atribuições de
especular sobre o que quer que seja
sobre o presente sobre o passado sobre
como essas duas esses dois tempos
diversos o passado eo presente se juntam
para determinar o futuro e tal
essas atribuições são interessantes pra
pessoas que se especializam nisso né se
dedicam a isso quaisquer campos de
atividade em qualquer campo de de de
reflexão se ocupam disse de juntar essas
peças junto a esses pedacinhos de coisas
e dizer o que é que como é que as coisas
estão andando e que a gente vislumbra
ali no meio do caminho e tal para alguém
como eu que não sou propriamente
dedicado a nada disso né
é uma dificuldade quando me disseram que
propuseram que eu viesse até os quinze
dias atrás falando com os organizadores
e dizer sim mas eu fui chamado para
fazer um show cantar lá na praça e uma
outra vez porque já tive aqui quando
quando eu era ministro da cultura
um dia li no jornal que a cidade de
piraí estava começando a mexer com a
questão digital cavar mobilizando sua o
seu só poder seus poderes públicos a
prefeitura etc etc pra fazer da cidade
de piraí o
o primeiro exemplo a filho na cidade
digital estabelecer elementos para o
pará que os serviços públicos municipais
se beneficiassem também da digitalização
de todo esse campo desenvolvido pelas
técnicas novas tecnologias etc
e eu me interessei muito por isso e
acabei vindo aqui é pra acabei fazendo
uma música que falava piraí piraí piraí
piraí banda larga ou se um pouquinho
piraí info viabilizou os ares do
município inteirinho com certeza a
medida provocou um certo vento de moinho
que era pra dar conta desse primeiro
dessa desse fato interessante de que a
pequena cidade do interior do brasil
ainda que perto do rio de janeiro mas é
inferior à anterior
ainda hoje você veja chega à cidade
pequenininha e pequena população
pequenas dimensões urbanas e já há a
música primeiro a saudar isso saudar
essa essa coisa de que eu era uma cidade
pequenininha que vinha dar um exemplo é
o brasil do mundo todo e depois porque
lá no ministério e naquela ocasião nós
estávamos exatamente dedicando muito da
nossa energia muito da nossa capacidade
de reflexão muito da nossa capacidade de
ação muito da nossa capacidade de
estabelecer políticas públicas etc pra
essas questões das novas tecnologias
para essas questões da do ciber espaço
para os grandes impactos que nós
começávamos a perceber que já estavam se
insinuando e que se multiplicariam nada
dali pra frente em relação a esse campo
então eu
a canção para saldar essas coisas todas
coloquei piraí na canção para dar esse
exemplo e lembra que na ocasião também
já já se tinha notícia de que paris
eu tinha viajado pra lá eu viajo muito
que aquela região toda a europa
todo ano e eu tinha ido a paris eu que
acho que me encontrar com o prefeito o
de lá o num um sujeito muito
interessante
homossexual assumido interessantíssima
figura e tal e que tinha começado também
uma digitalização da cidade de paris ele
começava a colocar sinais de de internet
nas praças de paris é de 160 ele saiu
para está fazendo isso começando a fazer
isso piraí está fazendo enfim fiz
naquele dia naquela época fiz a música
pra salvar essa advento tão interessante
mais um na humanidade não é mais um
renovando as esperanças mais um
restabelecendo a a capacidade de de de
considerar a sociedade humana como
alguma coisa que pode ser salva que pode
que pode valer a pena que pode enfim não
não ser apenas motivos das nossas
constante lá constantes lamentações mas
que pode ser mesmo também o motivo da
não é da nossa alegria da nossa
satisfação ao perceber que lá adiante lá
no fim do caminho as coisas podem acabar
dando certo se não completamente certo
mas muito mais acertando e aperfeiçoando
o imperfeito e desprezando a perfeição
aperfeiçoando em perfeito e desprezando
a perfeição aperfeiçoando imperfeito e
desprezando a perfeição fazendo esse
jogo permanente que acha a gente sempre
acha que isso é possível ali
o ministério naquela época nós também
achávamos disso e foi um dos motivos por
básicos de eu ter vindo a piraí
primeiro eu vi quando o o pezão é hoje
no governo do estado naquela ocasião
acabando de de de saída da saindo tendo
acabado de deixar a prefeitura de piraí
onde a ele ao lado de vários técnicos
tecnólogos cientistas e empreendedores
ativistas sociais entre 160 tinham
proposto começado e em certa medida
implantado o piraí digital
então eu fui fazer primeiro uma visita
aqui a cidade
visitei vários locais daqui tive com o
pessoal da prefeitura percebemos a o
empenho que a prefeitura tinha naquele
momento de fazer com que os serviços
todos aqueles serviços municipais que
pudessem se beneficiar da digitalização
e pudessem com essa digitalização
agilizar a prestação desses serviços de
agilizar a absorção o modo de de receber
esse serviço por parte por parte do
público enfim tudo isso a gente pôde
verificar aqui é as escolas o modo como
as escolas estavam começando a se
beneficiar também da atividade
digitalização um projeto que eu acabei
conhecendo em outros lugares do mundo
com destino à austrália
lá no interior da austrália anos depois
eu fui visitar também uma comunidade
daquelas bem primitivas né dos
aborígenes daqueles que eles índios
negros de cabelos lisos naquela coisa
bem interessante que tem do ponto de
vista ético do ponto de vista racial que
tem lá na austrália talvez os povos mais
antigos do
eles falam em 50 mil anos
enfim é pelo menos de traços culturais
que acabaram passando pra cá e eu fui
nessa aldeia anos depois aos três anos
atrás depois de adquirir aí eu fui lá e
eu vi esse programa que nas escolas de
lá estava sendo implementado também com
a ajuda dos americanos americanos sempre
metidos nessas coisas todas
eles são pioneiros e eles têm e se essa
espécie de missão não é que eles
acabaram se atribuindo e nós todos
acabamos atribuindo a eles também essa
missão de serem os vigilantes do mundo
estão vigilando mundo todo o tempo todo
em todos os sentidos tanto nos mais
positivos quanto às vezes nos negativos
também que eles também gostam de
comentar a guerra de coisas desse tipo
mas eles lá estavam ajudando esse
pessoal das escolas
essas escolas lá na dessa dessa tribo
aborígine no norte da austrália a lançar
uma coisa que eu tinha visto aqui piraí
já nas escolas daqui por isso eu falei
das escolas que eu visitei naquela época
que era o 11 é computador por criança
quando laptop kyle que é um era um
programa ainda continua sendo um
programa americano depois tive com
vários dos idealizadores e fundadores e
e empreendedores deste programa na
califórnia em vários lugares que é a
coisa de oferecer a cada criança nas
escolas um computador para que elas
façam elas tenham possibilidade de
iniciação nesse campo da digitalização
aprendem primeiro a manusear os
computadores né
naquela época ainda era um problema hoje
em dia isso já está desaparecendo essa
questão está desaparecendo com os
celulares novos nos computadores de nova
geração e até para 60 com a a tática
gênero
acham que tudo é basta clicar na tela
está para morrer aqui tudo aprender
propriamente a mexer nessas coisas não é
um problema de escola cada vez mais
profundo nas ruas a gente aprende cada
vez mais essas coisas na rua no
escritório no quarto e no banheiro em
dirigindo o carro cada vez é maior o
número de pessoas que enfim dentro dos
seus próprios carros estão começando a
mexer nessas coisas
e aqui eu visitei visitando aquelas
escolhem aquelas escolas aqui eu vi que
o programa também estava pezão tinha com
a sua equipe trazido o programa pra cá
os computadores estavam sendo
distribuídos pelas crianças
as crianças estavam começando a aprender
a mexer com aquilo a que os impactos nos
próprios programas na na dimensão
curricular das escolas na constituição
dos currículos no desenvolvimento dos
currículos na no campo das exatas do
campo das humanas no campo da enfim dos
vários tipos de matérias começaram a
surgir esses impactos positivos meninos
começavam a entrar no computador
começava a ter acesso deu era um momento
em que em que a essas coisas chamam como
google apps é pra esses problemas todos
começavam a se desenvolver ea criar a há
atrativos muito forte pra todos os
lugares do mundo e as crianças começavam
a ter acesso a tudo isso e portanto os
impactos no currículo na educação
no dia a dia na relação dos professores
com as crianças e tudo isso já era muito
forte muito evidente aqui no piraí
naqueles aquela visita que eu fiz eu
pude perceber isso quando visitei e se o
programa lá na austrália com os
aborígenes eu pude ver a os
desenvolvimentos
similar parecido na mesma direção que
havia enfim sido possível estabelecer
que aquelas crianças lá no interior da
austrália e enfim aquela primeira visita
então a piraí foi uma visita de
reconhecimento daquilo que já lá no
ministério a gente tinha avaliado como
muito interessante muito importante já
parabenizavam vamos piraí
nós estabelecemos fizemos questão no
ministério de fazer contato com essa
equipe toda daqui de piraí que tinha
sido responsável pelo por essa
implementação desse trabalho aqui nós
contactamos um elenco de glee
conhecemos o franklin lá da frente está
aqui ele está ali é lá da universidade é
do rio de janeiro enfim e que veio com
sua extraordinária capacidade criativa e
com sua extraordinária intuição não é
propor e e e realizar aqui e vir aí esse
primeiro trabalho então aquela visita
foi uma visita extraordinária a visita
que me me animou muito pra manter o élan
daqueles meninos que lá comigo em
brasília enfim insistiam trabalhavam
para convencer o governo nosso governo
então governo lula e com e comecei os
governadores e convencer os prefeitos
etc de que essa era uma nova etapa de
que esse era um novo campo que precisava
ser imediatamente adotado como um campo
preferencial para políticas públicas
interessante setra então aquela visita
animou muito o meu trabalho ministerial
eu costumava dizer naquela época e ainda
hoje sinto que piraí foi foi uma grande
inspiração aquela pequenina atividade
que você
iniciaram aqui eu me lembro o pessoal
aqui explicando a questão das obras das
antenas não é o os provedores dessas
grandes empresas de telefonia que
instalam embu foram instalando suas
antenas aqui piraí eles eles eles
cederam parte da capacidade ociosa
daquelas antenas para que os projetos
digitais de piraí na área de comunicação
e artes eca pudesse ser feitos então
aquilo inspirava também a parceria
público privada que era um dos eixos de
trabalho um dos eixos de noção de nova
noção política que que a gente começava
a ter um ministério presidente lula era
muito cioso daquela necessidade de que
as parcerias entre os governos e os
empreendedores privados se dessem cada
vez de forma mais profunda cada vez de
forma mais extensiva então piraí foi uma
inspiração para nós também lá no
ministério
depois logo depois
é dessa visita eu fui chamado aí já com
já tenha feito a música tudo mas eu fui
chamado pra mim fazer um show aqui eu
vim a cantar na praça encantar com o
pessoal aqui em piraí tô voltando agora
dez anos depois do projeto the digital o
pezão franco e todo mundo ainda aqui
ainda amamentando não tomar amamentando
o bebê já estão puxando do bebezinho
estão puxando moleque pela mão
aprendendo a andar e piraí dando seus
primeiros passos nesse campo continuando
a inspirar o brasil e nós todos no mundo
é pra esse projeto que enfim vocês com
sua visão cônsul se um seu pioneirismo e
seu extraordinário amor pelo futuro da
nossa humanidade brasileira iniciaram
aqui eu vim aqui pra não falar nada
mas é assim mesmo
eu quando quando encontrei domenico ali
atrás do méxico
o médico que fez uma exposição aqui
muito bem colocada muito bem inspirada
aristóteles etc etc
eu falei pra ele mas eu não tenho nada a
falar
eu acho que eu vou pedir 18 minutos de
silêncio
o pessoal então considerem essa fala que
nós tivemos aqui como nosso 18 minutos
de silêncio dedicados ao futuro da
humanidade
muito obrigado a você
piraí piraí piraí piraí banda larga ou
se um pouquinho iraí for viabilizou os
ares do município interior você queijo
china matou o vento despedimo em piraí
piraí piraí
obrigada